[Inaudible].
Nope, not Jesus. It's just me.
What the hell is going on? Oh yeah. Um, yeah,
I was working on this program and, um, yeah, I, I think I figured it out.
I think I got the formula. So basically if you merge the projection equation,
wait, wait, wait, what are you doing? Oh, right.
Okay. Let me just show you, let me just finish up real quick.
[Inaudible]
I don't follow it. It's incredible. Isn't it?
So all of this,
just to render a donut on your terminal.
One,
thanks for watching the idea and code work originally from the amazing and
the Sloan,
where he was able to coat this whole program in C and made the
code itself, look like a donut.
He has an article explaining how the code works,
which I'll link in the description. So why is math important for programming?
Well, it's because even if 99% of the time, you won't need it,
there's a 1% chance that you might,
and it's in those moments that separate out a great programmer from average
ones. And if you do know your math,
you'll know how to modify this donut to increase the size, changed a rotation,
or even make a cube. Instead. Also,
if you want to do computer graphics, machine learning or cryptography,
you're going to need math. So might as well get good at it.
As you did programming anyway, back to the donut,
how do we write this program? Well, first you have to create a donut,
which is essentially a solid of revolution,
where we have a circle that rotates around the y-axis,
which will make a donut, AKA a tourist.
This is the formula to create the circle centered at our two with the
radius R one.
And this is the rotation matrix to rotate this circle around the Y
axis. So when we combine them,
we get the coordinates of every point on your donut.
Now that we have a donut shut up, I know this is a bagel.
Now that we have a donut,
we want to rotate it around the X and Z axis.
So it looks cool or flying and stuff.
We can do that by multiplying our donut coordinates with these two rotation
matrices.
Now we have to map this 3d flying doughnut onto a 2d
screen, which will become our terminal.
So each character on the terminal will be a pixel on the screen
to figure out how to shade our donut.
We calculate the dot product of the surface,
normal and the direction of the light. So as you can see,
when the normal points this way, it's way brighter.
And when it points it that way, it's a way darker.
So the dot product will tell us how light or dark it is.
We take the result of the dot product and map it into DS
characters from darkest to brightest. And lastly,
we draw that on our terminal and voila,
if you like the way I teach,
you can check out my new course on data structures and algorithms,
where I use easy to understand animations, to explain these concepts,
the first a hundred people to sign up for Joe mCLASS, uh,
will get 15% off Joe mCLASS.